la mission était à l'origine d'attirer l'
attention nationale, maintenant elle a attiré l'attention mondiale,
nous avons même la Maison Blanche qui en parle,
vous savez,
oh mon Dieu,
faites-le le nourrir
[Musique]
que nous sommes de fiers chauvins occidentaux
que nous ne sommes pas désolés d'avoir créé le
monde moderne
que nous responsabilisons l'entrepreneur nous
vénérons la femme au foyer
que nous sommes vraiment le premier amendement nous
voulons que tout le monde puisse dire ce qu'il
veut
ou à quel point c'est fou
[Musique] [
Musique]
donc
[Musique]
ce petit groupe de  les hommes que vous voyez
derrière moi qui portent du noir et du
jaune
ont pu faire beaucoup de changements
à Portland au cours des dernières 48 heures
et euh ça m'excite et ça me
rend fier
tu sais parce que Portland aujourd'hui aussi fou que
ça en a l'air  Portland aujourd'hui est un
endroit beaucoup plus sûr qu'hier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu veux les appeler comment veux-tu les
appeler donne-moi ton nom donne-moi une
surprise blanche
et écris les problèmes prends du recul et  reste
à tes côtés
[Musique]
je ne sais pas qui sont ces fiers garçons, je veux
dire, tu dois me donner une définition
parce que je ne sais vraiment pas qui ils sont,
je peux seulement dire qu'ils doivent se retirer,
laisser les forces de l'ordre faire leur travail,
toi